on the 13th
of may
1884
which happens to be just 49 years ago
this week
i was a student at the ohio state
university
president mendenhall a notable teacher
was a professor of physics
in electricity
he had the faculty of making
quite clear and understandable those
fundamental relations of voltage and
current of inductance and capacity
and the like
and the
cgs system of units
after graduating and taking my ab degree
a year later
i remained for a time studying
analytic mechanics and working in the
electrical laboratory
and then i went to johns hopkins for a
year and a half
a little later the
uh threatened receivership led to the
dissolution of the school
and i
looked for a job
i visited my old friend henry umphrey
at the uh
tunnel where he was trying to make 16
candle power incandescent lamps
overcome the
smoke of the locomotives
at the end of the tunnel
he showed me a little shack
with engine and dynamo
which his head was the westinghouse
system
of alternating current
that was new idea to me
he explained the
converter uh we now call them
transformers
uh and i said why yes that's a that's a
room corp coiled backwards isn't it
with a letter of introduction which he
gave me i
met a contractor in philadelphia who was
wiring the bottom local motorworks
after an hour's argument he tried to say
goodbye pleasantly by suggesting that i
work a week for nothing
and they would charge me nothing for the
experience
but after a week of 10 hours a day
i did get a job
at 10 and a half a week
i was helper and wireman
draftsman and foreman
and
ran the dynamo on one of the uh night
ferry boats over to camden then the job
shifted to plainfield
and after a little while it disappeared
i had uh
six months rich experience
and the last month's page still coming
to me
well
during the evenings
i found
william stanley's paper on automating
current aie paper
a regular gold mine of information
i visit pittsburgh
i got lots of inspiration from a meeting
of the national electric light
association
could get no job at westinghouse
so i went on home in ohio
uh conducted a correspondence
which i followed up by a visit to
pittsburgh
and then on the 13th of uh
of august 1888
at six o'clock in the evening i began as
assistant in the testing room
it was before the days of self-harming
bearings and we had to
pour oil in the bearings a little while
and wipe the shaft in
and keep the voltage constant and read
the thermometers
and sweep out the rough wooden floor
all for 11 cents an
hour uh presently i was transferred to
the laboratory where schallenberger had
just invented his meters still well his
regulators and tesla was experimenting
with the induction motors
those were the days of cut and try
methods
and many of the technical mysteries
which battled us are now
taught to
college students
you